hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Marie
breeze back people-people I've been
asking you know I I saved this actually
like a whole for people like a whole six
actually huh Oh Marie I think all these
people deserve a little shout out from
you guys that's it if you're gonna make
them a collective you have six
individuals and you don't want to give
us a lot of people I McGeehan um what uh
specifically asked for a shout out from
me so hi you a thoughtful comment this
is very nice of you
Vinnie and he said specifically shout
out from Marino's green why are you look
so comfortable doing this last do we
have here Nicola Nicola scars so I bad
says he misses me I miss you too baby
Revenge of the Joker's is we went marine
I have to assume that that's um several
people would want to count thanks guys
here is a My Little Pony fan name blank
tray fallen friendship is Magic thank
you we're friends
jiggly Joey Ryan was where's me hi Ryan
where's my girl Marie I got a disease
and the only cure is more more a fist
bumps and long back to you yes
that's funny if anything this bouncing I
love this my plan was let's start off
the video with Marie give me shout outs
will get a lot of high octane energy in
here because shout outs are always very
enthusiastic and you have greatly
provided that energy well thank you so
much and I'm actually in fault you
didn't insult any of them that's an
improvement that's an improvement your
sponsor has been really talking you
about that and you're doing a great job
[ __ ]
yeah he's a piece of [ __ ] I don't like I
was talking about the subscriber oh wow
I don't know I guess they like you that
way we're gonna watch the trailer for a
video game called dying light I don't
know much about this game do you know
anything about it I know it is a
survival horror game it's a survival
horror game with zombie zombies yeah her
dough is actually supposed to be the
sequel the Dead Island like I think it's
the same creators I have not played did
I uh I've seen trailers of that
not actually like consume any anything
but like we don't do anything but
trailers no no movies no games yeah I
haven't seen a single movie in forever
all my reviews [ __ ] oh she's just
going running tomatoes and say what
everyone else is saying
put her in a collective I could probably
get away with that if I actually did I
don't do that every Oracle I also I got
through my English classes in high
school oh nice
wait what and as I connect I don't get
it not run - maybe now you look up you
look [ __ ] up on spark notes and then you
okay act really invested in it I thought
you went on rotten tomatoes and to help
you pass your English class I was
compared to Rotten Tomatoes map for the
Great Gatsby moving anyway guys uh yeah
it's a zombie I hate what I know about
it is that there's one really cool
feature in it is that like it takes
place during day and night and during
the day you have to be like a total
Walking Dead kind of survivor you know
gathering supplies and [ __ ] and then at
night is when like the zombies become
like crazy [ __ ] powerful one can run
at you so that's what I'm warned you're
like hiding and sneaking around more so
yeah I think it's cool to have both you
know I can relate to both really well
that baby is going berserk that mother
needs to slap that baby as soon as
possible
fake it slap it now shake slap shake a
one-two slap would be good for the baby
gonna start off young child abuse it's
the way to go
here at the real region we can no child
of you oh one of the meanest videos I've
ever done
alright alright I was dark just like
this trailer we're about to woman baby
stop crying
night rolls in like a blacktop and when
it leaves it takes a piece of you listen
the memory of who you were before falls
further into that dark abyss we were
doctors teachers fathers sons but so are
they these were monsters they've lost
the light behind their eyes and the
darker the day gets the more vicious
that become
we're all that's left when we fight
every day to hold on to what made us
good who made us human
they made Milwaukee disability king
that's big and every night was more of
ourselves to the darkness
whoa
ah
what happens when all that was good
enough is gone what would that monster
look like
he enough to kill that kid I think yeah
child abuse like what we were talking
about earlier this all taken this all
ties in our intro and now this what I
did like about it was the what look like
gameplay is that when he's running
around it does have that vibe of [ __ ]
there's a lot of zombies that you have
to move fast
you know it does have that frantic vibe
about it which which i think is pretty
cool the capturing a video game like
that I mean I think is it's typical
survival horror but you have to get like
to have a gun in mode own now I I'm kind
of I am tired of shooting zombies yeah
it did look like they I'm not too
familiar with the Walking Dead games but
I'm very familiar with the show and I'm
like they just saw The Walking Dead show
and turned into a video game like that's
exactly what I just saw a trailer I mean
it looks it looks like it could be cool
I guess I mean it's something that like
the trailer enough wouldn't intrigue me
I feel like I'd have to actually like
sit down and play a game for a while to
be like oh yeah this is worth it yeah do
you thought I did and then I lost the
thought Oh common I might have you ADHD
yeah me too yeah
do you have adderall that's right
adderall a lot of cocaine help me
concentrate too and I also but I like to
balance it out with a little bit of LSD
usually in middle of the day like 4 p.m.
I really you know what helps loosen you
up again yeah it does it does it's like
a relaxing the heroin dude have you ever
tried heroin oh yeah I mean like cuz
it's it's like a warm blanket thanks but
that is the best way to describe heroin
like a warm blanket we condone heroin at
the real rejects channel people heroin
to relax you feelin depressed hair
heroin verse word of heroin is here oh
he's gonna save you or she's gonna save
it yeah anyway guys um thanks for
recommending that trailer if you're new
to the channel you can click this button
up here it tells you to subscribe so
subscribe a memory doesn't have a
channel so I'm gonna put another link
here telling you to subscribe to the
real rejects hey so uh Murray's gonna
get off
phone we're gonna do some shoutouts eat
poo poo 62 love the name love the name
reminds me of my childhood Ryan dude bro
man shout me out I [ __ ] love you in
your videos shitty haircut though
Sally sexy interesting there's were a
lot of facts that were stating in that
one I like his hair I like my hair now
too buddy
I just started liking you now I gotta
read your comment need to poop poop more
light eat [ __ ]
wait that's same meaning that wasn't an
insult at all Marie help me out here
here's good at the insults [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you you call me bastard why yeah I don't
know it's just always insulting
Nicholson when I come anyway I love you
eat the poops 62 Murray loves you too we
all love you Murray and I have a penis
that is extending right now we shared a
singular penis it's a it's really long
though so it's pretty cool because we
get to uh you know we get to be Siamese
twins but you know we could still like
go places we have this work is it like
going the community I guess it's just
really stretching all the way from your
penis to mine and I don't know how a
urinate like it like comes like like we
both like they come together in like
intersect at the end is that what you're
I think so because that first time
everything that like we shared like I
hit like like we share to him no I'm
saying we share a penis like a singular
penis I have a fits like basically like
I'm here you're here and in the middle
is our penis what am i imagining it's
sort of like a triangle I gotta do you
understand what I'm saying like yours
like like it's like here's like where
like Ryan like the base of it is for him
and here's the base of it for me and it
comes in at the end like at the head and
becomes one penis and it's just going to
be like three feet long
will lead to boob that so you help us
come up with their Xandra brow shoutout
smiley face
well Wow what we need like a sinister
villains out out
it looks like the Mario Brothers that's
in your YouTube thumbnail man cool
that's cool are you into the morning of
brothers me too
who the [ __ ] isn't right yeah I grew up
playing the Mario Brothers man you know
I had a brother too he was kind of like
a Luigi to me something was older banana
man that was crazy faces he's a fielder
brother Luigi's older is he I don't know
it's taller he may be the younger one I
understand that taller sibling
well i think i'm a taller siblings are
usually younger except if you're like
male female female still time growing up
growing up my older siblings were always
taller than me huh well are your
siblings female or male a little bit of
both
a little bit of both she have like
hermaphrodite ones um a little bit a
little bit of hermaphrodite in your
family interesting
here's a drew brow yeah good for you um
I don't know how we've got two away know
I remember Luigi you you started this
whole conversation we're [ __ ] pervert
just credible nine love your videos bro
can you give me a shout-out respect from
Australia Australia Aussie I'll be
walking on my Aussie accent
cuz ever Adele buying half
I think shall only being Australia
mental I is the nice girl she won't
cheat on her boyfriend damn you anyway
yeah do you thanks for loving my vid
visibles my videos man you're you're a
bro you're a real bro word we're to your
mother too
I [ __ ] her last line is great I [ __ ]
her actually like 18 years ago you who
are our child I thought it'd be good to
reveal my son but so that's called when
you have a child out of wedlock he's a
bastard ah I know what am I considered
baby daddy oh yeah you would be the
baby daddy what did they call Arnold in
that situation when he had a fan I had a
kid Donald Schwarzenegger who the bug
other Arnold's you know well you said to
Arnold you say Ahnold dear Arnold again
ah no my name's Arnold Schwarzenegger oh
wait what the Governator that's how what
they called him like when you had a
child out of wedlock with another woman
I forgot the actual term for it anyway
it doesn't matter that's what I am to
you